I'm sure you've all used Google Maps
whether it's to get directions to a new
restaurant or stock someone's house
through street view we're all familiar
with the tremendous resource that is
Google Maps something that most of us
likely take for granted is that just
like all of Google's other products Maps
is completely free to use for as long as
you want this sort of Premium model
isn't too surprising with search or
email where everything you need is
virtual but Maps is a pretty grueling
business that requires a lot of physical
resources from the dozens of satellites
and hundreds of street view cars that
constantly Monitor and take pictures of
the earth to all the servers and
supercomputers required to complete
millions of hours of processing to
seamlessly stitch together pedabytes of
data and let's not forget about all the
hours spent on blurring our license
plates faces houses and other personally
identifiable information clearly there's
no question that Google Maps takes a lot
of resources to keep functional and up
to dat
and while its value proposition to
Google wasn't too clear in the early
days Maps has grown to be one of
Google's most lucrative businesses in
fact Morgan Stanley estimates that
Google Maps will pull in over 11 billion
in Revenue in 2023 alone for perspective
that's about the same as Tik Tok and if
we valued Google Maps the same way as
alphabet Google Maps itself would be
worth roughly $62 billion that's about
the same as Mercedes-Benz and more than
Volkswagen and PayPal heck that's enough
to be a top 250 Company by itself but
how does Google even monetize Maps they
don't show video ads or search ads and
there doesn't seem to be much
opportunity to collect and sell our data
based on just our Google Maps usage well
it turns out that Google has come up
with some pretty creative ways to
indirectly monetize Maps while staying
surprisingly ethical so here's the
insane rise of Google Maps and how
Google Maps really make so much m
money taking a look back the story of
Google Maps takes us back 20 years to
2003 like many of Google's products Maps
wasn't something that Google created in
house it was actually something that
they bought from four men named LS rasm
Jin rasm Noah Gordon and Steven ma
together they had founded a startup
called it were 2 Technologies in Sydney
Australia the idea for the platform was
pretty simple create a next gen desktop
map platform but it turns out that this
was a lot easier said than done and
pretty soon they needed a lot more
resources leading them to meet up with
Google in late 2004 initially Google
wasn't actually all that convinced about
where to Technologies until the founder
suggested the idea of converting the
desktop application into a web platform
that could be accessed much more easily
with that Google would agree to take a
flyer on the company for an undisclosed
amount which was likely well below $50
million word two technologies wasn't the
only map-based company that Google
purchased in 2004 though around the same
time they would purchase two other map
companies called Keyhole and zip Dash
like where two technologies Keyhole was
a desktop application but unlike where I
Technologies kho was more focused on the
macro scale AKA viewing the entire Earth
and various countries as opposed to
specific streets and directions I don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
this is what would turn into Google
Earth and Google would get this entire
company for just $35 million but in
terms of value nothing comes close to
their third acquisition zip Dash in fact
zip Dash might be Google's most bang for
buuck acquisition of all time as they
were able to purchase this company for
just $2 million what did zip Dash do you
ask well they specialized in using
location data from mobile phones to
create approximate real-time traffic
data this Tech would be underappreciated
and underused by by Google for several
years but once smartphone started taking
off all of that would completely change
but anyway going back to 2004 after all
the Acquisitions were done Google would
spend a few months refining the
Technologies before finally launching
Google Maps on February 18th 2005
apparently Google Maps would get slash
doted the night before its launch if you
also don't know what that means it
basically means that Google Maps went
viral on a form the day before launch
which led to an explosive launch right
out of the gate but this traffic didn't
last you see for a lot of us myself
included 2005 Probably sounds like the
stone ages when it comes to the internet
but it turns out that there were already
some pretty great mapping Solutions on
the market before Google Maps
specifically Yahoo maps and map quest
and while Google Maps was Superior to
these offerings from day one that by
itself was by no means enough to
displace the market leaders for most
people yaku maps and map quest already
accomplished what they needed and they
had no reason to use Google Maps instead
so the general consensus for year 1 was
that Google Maps did just okay it pulled
in a decent amount of traffic but
nothing too crazy Google could have
easily just called it right here and
kept Maps a small side business but they
were determined to make maps much more
than just that and as such they would
scrap everything and start
over
given the underwhelming response Google
would decide to do a complete rewrite of
Google Maps it turns out that while
Google Maps was better than Map Quest
and Yahoo maps for modern standards it
was still rather slow so their number
one goal with the rewrite was to
maximize speed and optimize the user
experience and after about a year of
work they would get the platform to be
nearly instantaneous allowing them to
make much more ambitious moves starting
with satellite view Google would stitch
together all of the imagery that they
got from the keyho acquisition to create
satellite view fun fact satellite view
isn't actually satellite view in most
cases it's actually aerial view taken
from low-flying Planes the map team was
actually debating on whether to call it
aerial mode or satellite mode but when
Sergey Brin made the decision to call it
bird mode the rest of the team would
decide to unite and defy Sergey by just
calling it satellite mode apparently
Sergey wouldn't ever comment on this
name change
but anyway satellite mode would come out
in late 2005 and this was immediately a
selling feature for Google Maps putting
the actual utility of satellite mode
aside most users just like messing
around with it being able to see your
house and City from a bird's eye
perspective was super neat you kind of
felt like you were a top secret spy or
something Google would simply take this
novelty to the next level on May 29th
2007 with the debut of Street View
street view was obviously an extremely
ambitious project Google was basically
signing up to bankroll cars driving
around every single Street in the entire
world it did turn out to be a really
popular feature though now not only
could you see your City from an aial
perspective but you could literally walk
through the streets as if you were
actually there but while satellite mode
and street view definitely made Google
Maps unique and drove of popularity the
number one Trend that made Google Maps
ubiquitous was of course smartphones in
fact smartphone based Revenue accounts
for nearly 90% of Google Maps Revenue
which is not that surprising Android is
the most popular operating system in the
world used by billions of people and you
know what comes pre-installed on Android
devices it's of course Google Maps so
most Android users are naturally just
going to use Google Maps whether it's
the best or not just like how everyone
used to use yahu maps and map quest all
of this has allowed Google Maps to reach
over 1 billion monthly active users but
while they were eventually able ble to
get to a dominant position it was by no
means an easy road while Google was able
to acquire the core three companies that
make up Google Maps for less than $100
million actually making Google Maps
successful cost a lot more money
according to one Professor just The
Upfront cars cameras computers and
Manpower alone cost over $400 million
and Google never stopped updating their
imagery if anything they actually do it
more and more often with time so there's
no question that creating and Main
maintaining Google Maps has cost Google
billions of dollars over the years which
brings us into the question of the day
how did they make all of this
worthwhile Google's monetization
strategy when it comes to Maps breaks
down into two main categories given that
Google is an advertising company at the
core I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that the first category is ADS but
it's actually done in a really tasteful
helpful manner you know how when you pan
around Google Maps you see businesses
like Walmart and Home Depot and
Starbucks well listing a business or
location on Google Maps is actually
completely free and basically anyone can
do it provided you have the right
documents and rights if you want to take
this to the next level though with
custom branding and high visibility you
can pay Google a fee and basically make
your listing a premium listing to be
honest this seems like a win-win
scenario users are able to find
businesses more EAS ly with their logos
and companies are able to increase their
brand presence in a discrete
non-intrusive manner but all of that is
only half the story Google's other mode
of monetization is honestly far more
interesting which is apis you know how
when you go to a website of a restaurant
or a local bowling alley you'll
sometimes see a small map showing you
the location of the Avenue well
companies are able to do this thanks to
Google's map apis for which they have to
pay and that's more of a small use case
imagine what happens when someone
someone like FedEx Uber Airbnb Zillow or
door Dash Implement Google Maps all I
can say is that that would cost quite a
bit of money and that's just the most
obvious implementation of Google Maps
likely the most commonly used Google
Maps API actually has nothing to do with
maps directly you know how when you
start entering in a billing address or a
shipping address the address autofills
well that's thanks the Google placees
API basically every company in the
entire world who collects address
information uses Google places or a
direct competitor like Microsoft's Azure
Maps if they don't they're probably
stuck in the 1990s on a peruse basis
Google Places is relatively cheap it's
only about 3 cents per use but think
about how many times you yourself might
use this every year maybe 10 times per
year that itself is 30 cents worth of
revenue for Google if 3 billion people
were to do this every year that itself
is $1 billion worth of revenue for
Google from just one API
I think you can start to see how all of
this can add up to 11 billion when you
throw in hundreds of different apis and
use cases but even putting the
financials aside thanks to Google Maps
Google has been able to map out the
entire globe in pinpoint detail this
means knowing the exact address and
location of any and every commercial and
residential property in the entire world
and if that itself wasn't enough they
also know the exact location of billions
of people on this highly detailed map at
any given point in time if that isn't an
insane amount of power I don't know what
is and that's why even if Google Maps
never even made a single dime for Google
Google would be the real winner when it
comes to Google Maps the fact that
Google Maps pulls an 11 billion in
Revenue per year on top of that is
simply a bonus with historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times the they still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at Silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing on safety every
salow account is insured by $500,000 in
sipc insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experienced managing $373
billion worth of assets over the past 45
years so if you're looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below one business that has taken this
philosophy to even the next level is
WhatsApp check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next
one